out to robinson this time
chris paul stayed on his feet didn't go
for that ball fake
and instead charred it free out of
bounds
and you just learned you learned not to
go for that robinson ball fake initially
which he's used
effectively and you gotta remember too
he's a steals former steals leader
times two in his league now paul
stepping right into the passing lane
just
rips it away from robinson and throws it
off his body out of bounds
taking it on himself i'm sorry but they
were
they were drawn a minute ago this is
classic cp3
i'm on you like a cheap suit it's my
ball points enough of that
he's now my responsibility that should
be an offensive foul and it is
easy call there lowering the shoulder
butler right into the body of paul
who's doing a little bit of everything
here closing out this first half well
he's just trying to make sure his team
you know stays engaged here right where
they are jimmy butler he's coming in
like a bull there he is easy call
what do we always say if you bring that
chicken wing out
you're gonna get called for the
offensive foul absolutely and cp3 knew
that
every time and he knows jimmy butler too